[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute gibt es Creme
Brulee Donuts die viralen Creme Brulee
Donuts ich habe sie überall gesehen ich
habe gedacht jetzt muss ich ein Rezept
dazu machen ich bin Baumaschinen
wir gehen direkt über zur Zubereitung
let's go so die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben stehen wie immer hier
unten in der Infobox einfach
screenshotten einkaufen und unbedingt
nachmachen ich starte jetzt mit dem
Hefeteig dafür gebe ich mein Mehl schon
mal in die Schüssel ich benutze jetzt
zwar die Küchenmaschine aber könnte es
auch mit deinen Händen machen so da
werde ich jetzt eine Mulde reinmachen
und dann kommt dann die Milch hinzu die
Milch muss unbedingt lauwarm sein und
sie darf nicht zu heiß sein ich habe sie
eine Mikrowelle erwärmen ungefähr 38
Grad wäre perfekt für unsere Hefe nicht
heißer sonst stirbt die Hefe aus und
dann wird der Teig nicht mehr schön
fluffig
so die Hefe jetzt da schon rein bröseln
wenn ihr euch nicht sicher seid ob eure
Hefe noch frisch ist man sieht das immer
wenn ihr das aufmacht das ist dann so
eine muschelartige Form ich kann euch
das gleich mal von der anzeigen dann
gebe ich dann gleich noch ein bisschen
was von unserem Zucker mit rein aber
nicht alles so ungefähr ein Teelöffel
der Rest kommt danach erst dazu das wäre
sonst zu viel für den Anfang genau und
dann lasse ich das kurz fünf Minuten
stehen
[Musik]
sonst können wir sehen dass die Hefe
schon mal schön vorgearbeitet hat man
sieht hier diese kleinen Bläschen und
jetzt gebe ich eigentlich alle anderen
Zutaten mit dazu also den restlichen
Zucker dann habe ich hier Butter die
habe ich in der Mikrowelle zerlassen bei
geringerer Zahl einfach mit dazugeben
und anschließend Prise Salz die hebt
noch mal den süßen Geschmack falls ihr
euch fragt warum immer die Prise Salz
bei süßen Rezepten mit dazu so und dann
habe ich hier noch drei Eier das sind
Eigelbe also ich habe mir wirklich
Gedanken gemacht weil ich denke immer
okay ich weiß die müde so viel Geld was
mache ich mit dem Eiweiß da gibt's
eigentlich ganz viele Ideen kann ich
euch mal Shorts zu machen aber ihr
braucht diese Eigelbe für die Konsistenz
und anschließend auch noch ein ganzes Ei
das könnt ihr dann einfach mit dem Teig
geben und alles schön kneten lassen
[Musik]
also Creme Brulee schreit ja nach
Vanille daher gebe ich in meinen Teig
Vanilleextrakt und später in die Füllung
und obendrüber kommt ihr diese leckere
Kruste aus Karamell so und ihr werdet
merken ob die Eier jetzt groß oder klein
sind also ich habe Eier Größe M
verwendet das würde ich euch auch raten
es ist auch noch okay aber l würde ich
persönlich jetzt zu groß finden so ihr
könnt euch sonst auch an den ähm an
Gewichte der Eier orientieren das
schreibe ich am besten meine Infobox das
ist glaube ich eine ganz spannende Info
für Euch wenn Ihr zu Hause Backen
vielleicht nur einer der Größe hat so
bei mir ist der Teig jetzt allerdings
noch ein bisschen zu feucht das macht
ihr daran dass wenn ihr anfasst das noch
ein bisschen klebt es darf auch nicht zu
trocken werden daher gebe ich jetzt für
immer so in drei vier fünf Gramm
Schritten noch Mehl dazu und knete das
weiterhin ihr dürft nicht so viel auf
einmal dazu geben weil wenn einmal
trocken ist dann ist es eigentlich schon
vorbei also schön langsam einrühren also
einkneten und dann schauen wir wie der
Teig aussieht
[Musik]
so jetzt ist mein Teig perfekt ich kann
hier anfassen das bleibt nichts kleben
er ist aber auch nicht furztrocken das
ist auch ganz wichtig so jetzt nehme ich
mir einmal noch den Teig einmal raus auf
meine Silikonmatte so super
die Maschine jetzt nicht so einmal noch
mal ganz kurz eine Minute mit den Händen
kneten zu einer Kugelform und dann gebe
ich es zurück ja in meinen Schüsselchen
ein bisschen backtrennspray rein ich
würde jetzt nicht noch mehr Mehl reintun
weil das Mehl verarbeitet sich ja beim
g-vorgang auch in den Tag und in dem
Fall möchte ich einfach nicht dass der
zu trocken wird da kommt es auf drei
vier fünf Gramm Mehl echt an manchmal
also ein bisschen backtrennspray rein
und unten oben einfach den Deckel zu
machen und dann 45 Minuten gehen lassen
[Musik]
während der Gehzeit machen wir den
Vanillepudding und jetzt dürft euch
nicht erschrecken ich habe nämlich an
euch gedacht muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
habe jetzt hier Vanillepuddingpulver das
ist eigentlich nur Stärke mit ein
bisschen Farbstoff und Aroma aber wisst
ihr woran ich gedacht habe jetzt noch
einen richtigen Pudding mit noch mal
drei Eigelb da werdet ihr mir 100%ig in
die Kommentare schreiben oh okay was
mache ich jetzt mit sechs Eiweiß daher
mache ich das jetzt so ich nehme jetzt
den fertigen Pudding aber wir pimpern
das noch ein bisschen also kommt hier
ein bisschen Milch mit rein sechs sieben
Löffel Esslöffel dann verrühre ich das
hier kurz Klümpchen frei aber nicht wie
auf der Packung 500 ml Milch nehmen
sondern 400 aber wie gesagt das steht
hier ALLES unten in der Infobox das gebe
ich hier in meinen Topf so da kommt
Zucker direkt mit rein und weil ganz
ehrlich so würden würde mir das wirklich
nicht in meine Creme Brulee Donuts Komma
das finde ich einfach zu lasch da gehen
wir einfach noch Vanille extra rein und
pimpen das
soweit ich muss ehrlich sagen ich wollte
auch so ein bisschen diese gelbliche
Füllung ich wollte nicht dass jetzt
komplett weiß ist weil das Auge ist mit
und das fand ich einfach ästhetischer so
jetzt gehe ich einmal rein und dann
Schneebesen verrühre das ganz kurz Herd
wird eingeschaltet und sobald ihr merkt
es wird warm die Milch steigt noch nicht
hoch sondern es bilden sich so kleine
Bläschen es wird wärmer kommt diese
Mischung mit hinzu und dann ständig
rühren und einmal kurz eindicken lassen
[Musik]
so direkt an der Oberfläche damit
Frischhaltefolie abdecken damit keine
Haut entsteht ich weiß es gibt so ganz
verrückte Menschen die mögen puddinghaut
Sarah schüttelt sich schon aber das
ganze jetzt einmal auskühlen lassen und
dann geht's weiter mit unserem Hefeteig
der Teig ist schön aufgegangen so
richtiger Ballon hier den gebe ich jetzt
einmal auf meine
Silikonmatte so und jetzt wird er
ausgerollt und zwar ca 2 cm dick also
nicht so flachrollen oh das fühlt sich
so runter so 2 cm dick ausrollen und
dann nehmen wir uns ein Ausstecher ich
nehme jetzt hier einfach ein Glas guck
mal gerade wie viel Zentimeter 7 cm
ungefähr im Durchmesser weit ich finde
dass diese Creme Brulee Donuts wenn sie
klein sind einfach irgendwie süßer sind
natürlich auch ganz große machen aber
ich mache heute ja etwas kleinere
[Musik]
so nachdem ihr ausgestochen habt
natürlich den überschüssigen Teig immer
wieder zusammen kneten und ausbreiten
wollen ja nichts verschwenden und die
dürfen jetzt hier noch mal 30 Minuten
zugedeckt ruhen denn dann werden sie
richtig fluffig also die Zeit müssen wir
uns auf jeden Fall nehmen zwei Gehzeiten
ganz ganz wichtig und dann machen wir
weiter dann geht's ans Frittieren so
jetzt konnten die Donuts ja noch mal
aufgehen ich sag übrigens Donuts weil in
Amerika sagt man ja dazu auch Donut bei
uns würden wir glaube ich eher Berliner
sagen oder in Berlin wenn man
Pfannkuchen sagen oder irgendwo auf der
Welt wenn man Palatschinken sagen ich
weiß nicht was sagt ihr denn dazu
trotzdem
Pfannkuchen sind Pfannkuchen
Krapfen ja schreibt mal rein was ihr
seid nicht mal interessieren die sind
auf jeden Fall gut aufgegangen und wie
gesagt immer schön zudecken und trocknet
die Oberfläche aus und ich habe jetzt
hier ihr könnt einen Topf nehmen ich
habe jetzt hier meine Pfanne die mit 28
cm Durchmesser und die hat halt so einen
hohen Rand deswegen eignet die sich
jetzt perfekt und ganz viele davon
auszubacken das Fett ist auf Temperatur
ich habe jetzt kein Thermometer es gibt
ein ganz einfachen Trick ein Holzstab
reinhalten wenn die Bläschen langsam
aufsteigen dann also zu langsam ist es
noch nicht so weit wenn sie zu schnell
aufsteigen dann ist es zu heiß sie
müssen wirklich mäßig hochsteigen ich
habe euch hier was eingeblendet dann
könnt ihr euch das Anschauen und daran
orientieren so und jetzt nehme ich mir
so eine Schöpfkelle und backstiefel dann
von beiden Seiten aus bis sie schön
goldbraun sind
[Musik]
also die frittierarbeit wäre erledigt
das ging wirklich sehr schnell und wenn
du jetzt wirklich einen großen Topf oder
eine große hochanfpfanne verwendet dann
könnt ihr das mit zwei Mal ausbacken
ungefähr drei Minuten also pro Seite
anderthalb Minuten ihr dürft gerne öfter
mal drehen das ist kein Problem
hauptsache sie werden schön goldbraun
sondern das machen wir noch Karamell
denn zum Creme Brulee gehört ja auch
noch was karamellis eigentlich flambiert
man ja aber in dem Fall machen wir
Karamell und dafür einfach einen am
besten eine gut beschichtete Pfanne
nehmen
die ist wirklich gut deswegen kann ich
da direkt mein Zucker rein Wasser rein
und dann einfach passieren lassen also
lasst es einfach schmelzen
karamellisieren nicht zu heiß denn sonst
wird es bitter und alles verbrennt daher
lasst euch da auf jeden Fall viel Zeit
und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal meinen kalt gewordenen Pudding
einfach mixen dann wird er nämlich
richtig schön cremig und einfach gar
nichts mehr dazu geben und das ist dann
für unsere Füllung
[Musik]
und parallel ist mein Karamell auch
fertig geworden dann müsst ihr euch aus
12 13 14 Minuten Zeit nehmen nicht
rühren sondern einfach wirklich
passieren lassen das ist ganz ganz
wichtig ihr könnt schwenken wenn ihr
merkt okay es wird in der Mitte schon
braun und außen nicht so aber nicht
rühren oder nicht mit irgendwie einem
Schneebesen reingehen so und jetzt
können wir eigentlich alles
zusammenstellen und das geht ganz
einfach ihr habt ja gesehen dass ich
hier ähm eine fülltülle genommen habe
die hat so eine Spitze hier vorne
verlinke ich euch genauso wie alle
anderen Sachen und die Zutaten natürlich
in die Infobox dann könnte ich das noch
mal anschauen so und jetzt nehme ich mir
einen Sohn hat und steche ganz
vorsichtig rein das ist so fluffig
wirklich jetzt gerade schon gesehen das
ist super fluffig das heißt ihr müsst
nicht mal irgendwie ein Loch vorstellen
oder so sondern einfach so ein bisschen
Füllung da reingeben ihr merkt dann
Widerstand so jetzt ist es voll und dann
kopfüber ins karamelltrunken und einfach
aushalten lassen an mein Tipp ist noch
vielleicht wirklich parallel weil
natürlich kann es sein dass euer
Karamell dann auch relativ schnell fest
wird auch hier in der Pfanne und wenn
das aber so sein sollte also lasst es
ein bisschen abtropfen dann könnt ihr
das noch mal ganz langsam erwärmen
wirklich Stufe 2 von 9 oder so denn wenn
Karamell anbrennt dann wird es bitter
und dann schmeckt's halt einfach nicht
mehr ach ist schön und wenn es dann aus
hätte kann man so richtig alles machen
[Musik]
also ich kann euch nur den Tipp ans Herz
legen immer wieder das Karamell erwärmen
denn es wird einfach zu schnell fest und
so könnt ihr wirklich dann ein bisschen
schwenken auch Vorsicht die ich gerne
notfalls auch eine Gabel weil sobald ihr
das mit den Fingern berührt ihr
verbrennt euch die Pfoten aber wenn ihr
so ein bisschen Erfahrung habt dann geht
das nicht verbrennen habe ich schon
gerade aber nur so ganz leicht nur das
deswegen man muss echt aufpassen
bekommt immer diese dünne Kruste und
nicht dieses dicke ich habe so ein zwei
habe ich gemerkt oh es wird langsam
wieder kalt das wird langsam härter
daher immer die Zeit nehmen und das
Karamell immer wieder auf Temperatur
lassen und deshalb macht es auch in der
Pfanne also nicht irgendwie
umdisponieren in irgendwie eine andere
Schüssel oder so
umzugehen immer so ja ich schwenke halt
immer dann den Rand damit ich besser
eintunken kann
[Musik]
geil
ja klar es ist rausgefluter ist auch
egal scheiße
ich gehe mal ganz gegen die Regeln ja
und ich weiße rein
morgen
das ist wirklich so das ist wirklich
eine 20 von 10 das sage ich echt geil
ich finde so perfekt perfekt
das macht die richtige Temperatur
gemacht
gemacht habe schmeckt echt gut
und wie passend dass es jetzt bald ein
Eiscreme Brulee Macchiato bei uns im
Café gibt das ist irgendwie Creme
Bulette aktuell
essen aber keine Lust selber machen ja
keinen Bock selber zu machen obwohl es
ging jetzt eigentlich echt es ging es
waren halt nur diese Wartezeit habe ich
die Küche aufgeräumt und ein bisschen
vorbereitet und das geht echt voll klar
es ist ein Traum macht unbedingt nach
abonniert meinen Kanal wenn ihr solche
genial Dinge nicht verpassen möchtet
nicht so groß ist das ist so
ein bisschen kleiner gemacht
guten Tag wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Mal tschüss sagen
tschüss
[Musik]